Speaker 1: All right. This is super serious.
And so we're not going to make light of this.
Lauren Boebert, the radical and repugnant,
sanctimonious Republican congresswoman who
talks about how Christianity is the one moral path
and Christianity needs to be involved in civil
government and all these different how everybody
else is a bad parent if they have a trans kid or
if they're gay or whatever. Okay. That Lauren
Boebert. Was potentially involved in covering
up her own then husband, soon to be ex-husband's
alleged child abuse against one of her own kids.
There is the story of the facts and there is
the story of Lauren Boebert. I know with Ronda
sanctimonious, it sounds crazy to use the word,
but her sanctimonious pleading about how she is
the moral one when she may have been involved in
this. So let me tell you what the allegations are.
In December, Lauren Boebert teen son called
911. And the reason that her son called 911
was to report that his dad, Lauren Boebert
husband, was abusing him, that he was, quote,
throwing me in the house. The teen sobbed through
the two minute call, saying he didn't understand
why his dad was mad. The boy called back soon
after, suddenly denying it happened. With Lauren
Boebert jumping on the call to say the boy is
fine. Okay. So two minute phone call. The teen
calls and says, My dad's throwing me around. I
don't know why. The call ends Garfield County
Sheriff's Office deputies are going out to Lauren
Boebert house. The teen calls back and says, Oh,
I take it back. And suddenly, Lauren Boebert is on
the phone and says, My son doesn't need any help.
Jason Boebert denied to the deputies that he got
physical with his son put out. Lauren Boebert put
out a statement yesterday saying The safety and
well-being of my family are the most important
things in the world. We've had tough times and
heartache. I've taken action to ensure there are
better days ahead, presumably meaning that she is
going to be divorcing her husband. An affidavit
says that when Jason Boebert was served with the
petition for divorce, he became extremely angry.
He started yelling and using profanity. And he,
Lauren Boebert, denied that. That's what happened.
When we go back to 2004, we know that Jason
Boebert was arrested and pleaded guilty to public
indecency and lewd exposure after allegedly
exposing his genitals to two young women,
one of whom was 16 years old, at a bowling alley.
Lauren Boebert defends her husband in her book,
claiming that he was actually the one who
was harassed by a female bartender who said,
Show me your genitals. So we have a
situation here where if it is true.
It appears as though Lauren Boebert
potentially realizing. The very bad
situation that it would be for her for police
to show up at her house just a few months ago,
potentially to arrest her husband for child abuse
that her son called 911 and said was going on. The
speculation is she made her son call and retract
that allegation that his dad, Beaufort's husband,
was becoming physically violent. And if that is
the case, she would be involved in a cover up of
child abuse. Now, we don't know that that is what
took place. We are still learning more about this,
but it's not about getting involved in the
personal lives of these individuals beyond
the fact that they want to They both declare
themselves the top and mightiest arbiters
of morality and ethics, and they go around
telling everybody else what they're doing wrong
based on sexual identity or gender or whatever the
case may be. And in addition to that, that they
stake a claim for their religion, which in this,
you know, with Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Lauren
Boebert and others, it's always Christianity, that
Christianity is the moral and ethical law of the
land that should be the law of civil government.
So they are sanctimonious hypocrites. Now,
whatever the truth is about whatever abuse what
one of Lauren Boebert sons may have suffered,
it's a law enforcement matter. But to the
extent that these folks want to make law
and tell everybody else what's right and what's
wrong, they are horrible, sanctimonious hypocrites